so Jason Hyatt has a question the earth
has a magnetic field that protects it
from space radiation is there any reason
why a magnetic field could not be used
on its spacecraft either for the whole
ship or as an emergency shelter an MRI
scanner produces a very strong magnetic
field why not a magnetic field generator
a la an MRI to protect astronauts that
is what a coincidentally happy question
right yeah if you had a strong enough
magnet yeah you could pull it off but
our problem so far as generating
enormous magnetic fields takes a lot of
energy need really how much a lot like
as much as a like a like a coffee maker
that's like supercharged be a little
more than that so like a boat like a
giant boat a cruise ship like a diesel
engine on a pretty long like a tugboat
diesel engine okay but that's more than
you would have on your average are you
nervous because I'm so heavy and giant
and we're yeah you don't want any big
stuff like that you don't want to fly
with a truck into space but just imagine
that defeats the purpose just imagine if
we had solar panels big enough and some
superconducting situation in the icy
blackness of space and you could create
a magnetic field strong enough that's
actually a science fictional kind of
cool engineering question but I think
when at least right now early in the
21st century we humans can't crank that
out we can't make such a thing but who
knows what the few that but if we
started doing more space exploration we
would potentially come up with that
technology down the line that's it seems
like something if you had that much
power yeah seems thanks power every but
there's other we do other things for for
space radiation like uh suits like like
space suits waters are pretty good
insulator action so really yeah and
shielding you know all the spill and and
we try to understand how much you you
take you know we always wear a dosimeter
when you go into space
oh really measure how much how much
you're taking are you exposed to like
when you were it's a pretty good dose uh
it also depends it also depends on where
you are spacewalks you get more than
when you're inside the spaceship at a
higher altitude by where we were at
Hubble as opposed to where the space
station Wow just a few hundred tens of
kilometers make a big difference right
in a length of time you're going to be
there and if there's solar flares when
you're up there so it's a bunch of
factors but it's nothing if you fly in
space for over a year or so like some
people have a combined over a year stay
they have to track it and make sure
you're okay that's when you start
getting a little bit curious but we have
astronauts who have flown Scott Kelly's
going to be up for a whole year as the
plan he's already been up over six
months in his life and seriously himself
in water yes yeah he's going to he he's
going to stay out of the Sun but when
you say what are you jacket the
spacecraft well for example water can
yeah so if you have a water bag like on
the space station you want to get some
extra extra shielding if you would have
to line the outside of your spaceship
with with water for examples you line
the outsider is there let me you're
inside means no there is no layer of
water I'm saying if you were trying to
if you were worried about a solar flare
for example your spaceship and you had
water bags that would help you that you
wish you add so you just think so no
you're thank you anyway yeah so use your
use it as a shielding let's keep you
frank irradiated water it's not that
irradiated it's fine you're not yeah no
it's fine it's great that's no problem
it's great there's nothing better than
irradiated water from space yeah back
it's probably a market for it this
problem somebody who really wants three
cool barn Brooklyn that sells a tofu
disc actually yes gonna be a good
question Eugene that's not bad go back
home wait a minute hold that thought you
guys we'll be back shortly at star talk
radio
you